Let's go run it and see.
On the buggy code we get -1, -1, -1, -1.
But if I fix the bug, then I get 5, -1, 8, -1.
That means these first two--
"haystack", "a" and "haystack", "empty"
show off the bug,
and the last two do not.
So the correct answer was, first one
and this other one on the left, but not the ones on the right.
You can also reason through the program qualitatively to get a handle on this.
We're only going to see this difference
if last_pos is not equal to this_pos.
Remember, this was the bug, and this version is correct.
So in order to see the bug, this_pos
will have to be different from last_pos,
which means we will have to have
found the string at least once.
We find the "a"--we find the other "a"--so this is a good example,
and then in fact you have to know a bit about Python to know
what it means to try to find the empty string in something.
But Python always says the empty string is present--
present at offset zero--it's going to be present at offset 1--at offset 2--
just like epsilon, it fits anywhere.
So there's more than one "a" in the string.
There's more than one empty string in "haystack".
So these are both good test inputs to show off this bug.
Since there's no "z" in "haystack",
last_pos and this_pos are both -1, so we can't tell the difference.
And since there's no "needle" in the empty string,
last_pos and this_pos are both -1,
so we can't tell the difference.
Testing is not easy.